في المقدمة الليلة، ننقل الأمر مباشرة إلى
بوتين، الجنود الروس الذين
يموت رفاقهم في القداس الليلة، ونناشد
الرئيس الروسي مباشرة للمساعدة، وقد
زودت قيادتنا وحدتنا
بجنود جدد تم تعبئتهم ست مرات الآن، وهذا
دليل على عدم كفاءة
رؤسائنا والقوات المسلحة.  يرجى المساعدة من الوحدة بأكملها،
لا يوجد مكان آخر يلجأون إليه
فقط لكسر ذلك، هؤلاء
الرجال المحشدون يقولون إن وحدتهم
قد تم تجديدها ست مرات، فكروا
في كل هذا الموت المروع
والأهم في هذا
النداء هو أنهم مباشرة
الرجال المعبأون يصفون
قادتهم بأنهم غير أكفاء ويوجهون الأمر
برمته، وليس مجرد برقية
لمنشور عشوائي، مباشرة إلى بوتين ليراه،
ويأتي ذلك في الوقت الذي لدينا فيه
المزيد من مقاطع الفيديو لجندي روسي آخر
يصف الوضع على الأرض في
شرق أوكرانيا بأنه  مجموعة من
دبابتنا تحترق هناك
تحية كبيرة للجميع مباشرة من
الخطوط الأمامية دليل مباشر على ما
يحدث هنا إنها مجموعة
لكننا ندفع المجد المقدس لروسيا،
هذه مقاطع الفيديو اللعينة تأتي كما هو الحال داخل
روسيا نفسها مجموعة فاغنر الوحشية
يزعم أنه يتجه إلى طلاب من
موسكو من أجل ملء صفوفها ونحن
نفهم أن الطلاب المعنيين
هنا هم في الصف العاشر وأريد
التأكيد على أهمية حقيقة
أن هؤلاء الأولاد موجودون في موسكو وهي
المنطقة الأقل إرسالًا
المقاتلون إلى الخطوط الأمامية، المنطقة
التي ظلت الأكثر عزلة
عن آثار الحرب حيث
يعيش المزيد من النخبة، هذا هو مقطع الفيديو لما
يُعتقد أنه لمقاتل فاغنر،
وجهه مغطى وهو في الفصل الدراسي
وهو يحاضر للطلاب حول  ما يسمى
بخدمة العقود الآن
يضطر الطلاب إلى ملء هذا
الاستبيان ونفهمه ويظهره لك على
الشاشة ويطلب معلوماتهم الشخصية
وكذلك معلومات الاتصال
بآبائهم
ويسأل أيضًا هل لديك أي أقارب
يعيشون في  الدول المعادية
وما هو مستوى لياقتك البدنية،
هل تمتلك أي مهارات عسكرية أساسية والتي تم
تفصيلها
كإسعافات أولية تكتيكية أو إطلاق نار؟
أريد أن أذكر أن CNN يمكنها
التحقق بشكل مستقل من هذه الادعاءات ولكن هذا يدفع لمزيد من
المجندين لمجموعة فاغنر ولا حتى
يأتي الجيش الرسمي الروسي في الوقت الذي يواصل فيه
بوتين قمع
المعارضة اليوم، ظهرت نائبة كبيرة سابقة
لزعيم المعارضة المسجون أليكسي نافالني
في قاعة محكمة روسية اسمها
ليليا تشاناسيفا، وهي
مسجونة بالفعل منذ عام وتواجه 18
عامًا أخرى إذا أدينت
بعد ذلك.  افتتاح مقر إقليمي
لمؤسسة نافالني لمكافحة الفساد
التي كشفت المؤسسة عن مثال تلو الآخر
عن
فساد بوتين في دائرته الداخلية